okay first of all reunited I know do we
feel better playing a couple or friends
it's different it's a little different
it's different yeah I think yeah there's
less affection yeah there in general
as you said you walk away yeah you can
walk away yeah my character just
cleanses his hands of the whole
situation from time to time which you
can't do if you're a married couple yeah
you're more than happy to just tell her
to deal with you you can't do that as a
yeah I don't know it's it's fun doing
both you know yeah it was different
though I realized oh I can't do that
this time no you know it's just a
different Dynamic but it was fun yeah
are you guys still learning things about
one another yeah at this point yeah
someone would be surprised to know
what I don't know what the average
person knows about right so that's hard
for me to project but
um what do you what well you told me a
few things but I don't want to yeah
[Laughter]
what about secret skills in real life I
know you can do choreography on tables I
can't even if you were a table dancer
yeah that was pretty good huh yeah I
picked it up faster than Luke which was
hilarious did you really oh much faster
much much much much much faster I got it
in like five minutes he he was in there
like a full day he went to choreographer
and everybody shot it he was like B
minus yeah
then we had to write it into the scene
that I was like showing him how to do it
because he just kind of couldn't do it
yeah rose has a good mood the physical
moves everyone's while I was like oh
that's physical
I love those moves so secret set of
skills anything Dancing Yeah singing
singing singing I was a good singer
good with animals good with animals very
good with animals
not afraid I love animals very
professional raccoons like diverse you
know not just dogs and cats or whatever
give me your weird animals
I know a lot of Canadians are interested
in buying sports teams right now
especially hockey they are yeah I don't
know Seth I'm not I am not interested in
buying his first team I wouldn't know
what to do with it
Ryan Reynolds I think he's trying to buy
a sports he's Snoop Dogg throwing his
head again for the Ottawa center really
oh wow you're Canadian I am I I don't
I'd say like I'm a you know one of the
reasons I became a comedy writer at 13
is because I did not like sports or have
a lot of friends
you don't start writing a movie when
you're 13 when you're the captain of the
hockey team I'll tell you that you're
busy doing other fun stuff
um so you guys you know your Dynamic is
just so great to watch and I really
enjoy it but if there was a crisis
what are an iconic best friends that you
guys would call to save the day like I
was at Thelma and Louise oh yeah they're
good ones are we thinking photo and Sam
Fredo and Sam were seem they seem
equipped to save some place
they'll have some idiosyncratic yeah
yeah all good ones it might not save you
but though yeah Frodo and Sam yeah
um and then obviously you guys being
producers on this and working together
in that way what was that like I feel
like you guys are so intertwined and
like besties it kind of felt like a
Natural Evolution from doing the movies
and this was a different take that we
chose to bring you know do this project
together and having Nick stall our
writer director in Francesca Del Banco
it was like a it was just a nice
reuniting of It's Always lovely when
you've worked with people before and you
have a good time and the product is good
and then you can find something else to
do so yeah it was great yeah it was a
fun summer yeah I've worked with Nick
since I was 18 so yeah it's a very it's
an easy relationship at this point yeah
yeah awesome thank you guys are
hilarious